le site d'enfouissement de lachenaie à
terrebonne
un des plus importants au québec le seul
dans la région de montréal en des soulac
y travaille depuis vingt ans la faune au
fond des choses on dépose vos déchets
les 17 40% des gens de montréal
chaque jour jusqu'à 800 camions
déchargent leur cargaison ici des
ordures mais aussi beaucoup de matière
recyclable que les gens jetés à la
poubelle papier carton verre on peut
retrouver des fois des pneus des matelas
qui sont reste l'os au québec dont il ya
plein mafart qui peut être recyclé qui
se renvoient pas d'avoir la bonne fille
à environ la moitié des matières
recyclables générées par les québécois
sont envoyés à l'enfouissement
comment peuvent apercevoir au front
deschamps retrouve beaucoup place
etats-unis beaucoup d'emballages
beaucoup d'appuis classique donc des
objets qui ont servi à envelopper
emballé d'autres objets la sac de
plastique placés et coutelas siècle
l'emballage le var
donc c'est énorme pour cette
environnementalistes ont des trous de
matières recyclables et encore des
commerces ou des centres de choquer on
va directement les matières ou au
dépotoir
si les coûts d'élimination étaient
beaucoup plus élevés qu'ils ne le sont
actuellement
on aurait peut-être moins de plastique
dans les dépotoirs mhz actuellement
malheureusement pour une compagnie qui
regarde un petit peu son budget
l'enfouissement coûte encore beaucoup
moins cher que les plages dans ceux ci
est en opération depuis 50 ans on
enfouit plus d'un million de tonnes de
déchets par année 20% de tous les
déchets produits au québec je plastiques
mais aussi du verre de la cueillette
sélective rejetée par les centres de
tris une qualité de voir qu'on reçoit
qui qui pourrait être rachetée mais que
nous on va valoriser en construisant des
routes avec des routes connues besoin
sur notre site
ça c'est du verre donc des gens familles
dans leur bac dans leurs opérations qui
se retrouvent ici c'est de voir que moi
vos portes cornichons bouteilles de vin
qui ont été déposées le ministre
québécois de l'environnement est bien
conscient du problème donc c'est une
situation qui se doit d'être corrigés
pour une raison fort simple est immense
et la confiance publique qui finit par
être miné ce sont les gens qui finissent
par se demander est ce que ça vaut la
peine toujours de naître au de faire ce
geste de faire cet effort de m la
bouteille de vin ou sinon contenants
plastiques dans le bac bleu donc la
réponse est oui selon recyc-québec 72%
du verre et 65% du plastique générés par
les québécois se retrouvent dans les
sites d'enfouissement
on produit trop de place et donc et
c'est sûr qu'un jeu ça se retrouva dans
les lieux d'enfouissement sera un
commerçant aujourd'hui un producteur
peut mettre sur le marché un produit non
recyclables moi je trouve ça je trouve
ça aberrant c'est à dire au moins
devraient s'assurer qu'un produit mise
en marché au québec soit recyclable et
recyclé parce qu'une grosse nuance et il
est allemand localement à lachenaie on
voit d'un bon oeil la promesse du
gouvernement trudeau d'interdire les
plastiques à usage unique dans deux ans
si son jeu d'un coup d'oeil plusieurs
hajek qui sont derrière moi ton
visuellement à part à ces objets qui ont
servi à peine une fois donc c'est eux
qui vont disparaître
ça va faire une différence qu'est ce que
tu as appris dit gilles andré va
continuer d'organiser plusieurs fois par
année des visites scolaires du site
d'enfouissement et de l' usine de
biométhanisation des visites pour
sensibiliser les écoliers à l'importance
de récupérer de recy clip réduire
utilisé eric fehr pourrait ce que les
composter si on prend les bons choix et
par deux fois même peut-être 10 pour
mettre des chalets belle donc moins de
problèmes à gérer
ici jean philippe robillard et du canada
montréal